we have a CodeRed situation we're gonna
make some changes we're installing
sensors underneath everyone's desks we
want you to be the face of this
initiative this is a chance for you to
step into a management role I knew this
day would come
[Music]
look like so super good today we want to
create a culture of shapes do you two
have death sensors know where your
superiors and above the law but whirls
are your friends and the same as all of
you
Hampton Deville welcome to help hi I
work at Hampton develop where do you
work very soon I go 35 times a day Jesus
you have claws what are they I got
married Lauren its Laura what my name is
Laura oh man I am officially off the
market let's definitely stay in touch
I'm desperate to stay in touch
[Music]